what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so getting into the iron nail the story
when Steve Rogers loses the Super
Soldier Serum this is super cool like
it's definitely one of my Captain
America my favorite Captain America
stories because it just seems like a
natural progression right I mean we knew
as the reader that like a time will come
when Steve Rogers will just stop being
Captain America and it makes sense I
mean after a while you'd only ever tell
so many stories there's only so many
times where you can read about Steve
Rogers running into the battlefield plug
gingers a symbol freedom like there's
only so many times of course like okay
let's get something a little bit new but
the idea here was that witness initially
dropped it was very divisive in the
community people absolutely began to
freak out you know Captain America
purists lost their minds they could not
imagine anybody besides Steve Rogers
playing the role of Captain America they
were just kind of trapped in that
mindset at the same time you had people
who wanted to see Captain America kind
of just remain the hero that they always
envisioned they weren't really locked in
to the character but for them it's just
Steve Rogers as always Captain America
so it created kind of like one of those
interesting scenarios but for me I
always loved this I always loved this
story I love the ideas simply seeing
somebody else carry the mantle even if
it was only going to be for a temporary
amount of time or even if it was
permanent I always thought it would be
kind of cool and in truth I loved what
Hickman did with with Captain America
and Avengers and New Avengers worries
just like this old man cynical and angry
at the world and just like running
shield trying to get revenge on the
Illuminati it was kind of cool it was it
was really an interesting concept but
again what we also get is this depiction
of what it is that dr. mind a bubble
does in the sense that remember in the
last video we talked about how nuke was
just this crazy military guy he was
basically trying to win Wars fitted long
since been overran so he was going into
international territory - going into
other countries in the sovereign states
shooting there people are planting
American flags and it threatened to
create an international incident and so
the result was that he was basically
captured by Captain America and Sam
Wilson as Falcon and then kept prisoner
on a shield Helicarrier only for us to
find out that he was being used by the
iron nail Obama was put inside of him
and he was detonated resulting in the
deaths of some 160 some Rodney no shield
agents the destruction of the
Helicarrier and Newton south and so
again what doctor Mind bubble does or at
least what what this little tidbit does
is it basically picks up with playing
Simpson having single-handedly won the
war and that's really what his dream is
and that's how
doctor mind bubble works he has the
ability to manipulate reality around
individuals but only insofar that he
trapped their minds inside of a reality
bubble so he's not like Franklin
Richards like molecule man or anything
like that
he can't inherently alter reality itself
he somebody just kind of creates an
illusion inside the mind of the people
who were trapped in its metals and then
they believe it to be an absolute truth
and so because of this this is really
just designed to by mind bubbles who
essentially allow Frank Simpson to
experience the the passing of a process
without really suffering or struggling
now choosing the guy's got a giant hole
in his chest so I guess it kind of works
but the fact remains here that we also
have mine bubble encountering ranch in
now keep in mind ranch in the iron nail
had been the hidden hand behind all of
this
he it had been on this campaign to take
down shield for years and years and
years and years and again a lot of this
is rooted in the fact that he felt
betrayed by shield in the sense that he
wasn't agent at one point long line he
was assigned to infiltrate Communist
China he eventually became this kind of
corrupted guy by having the shine of the
Shaolin scientist squad as Shaolin
scientist squad their ego was ultimately
you know kind of OWL stood by Mao
himself and then eventually recaptured
by shield again and so they kind of that
you know he'd essentially lost his mind
he'd kind of gone drunk with power and
so the result was that he's basically
waging a war against he'll and trying to
bring down shield in its entirety now in
truth this is kind of a reflection of
the larger picture Giotto is only one
facet for a ranch in it's really more of
taking down the establishment taking
down all these various individuals and
we see this play out when we end up
having you know Captain America and jet
black again the kind of you know
dimensional displaced daughter of Arnim
Zola walking side by side now the cool
thing about this is is keep in mind the
Rick Remender is not teasing any sort of
romance here and he's not really saying
you know well jet black and Steve Rogers
they might become something it's not
really gonna work that way
in truth jet black its battle-hardened
she views the world wildly different
than Steve Rogers does she's ruthless
she's like look there are two types of
people in this world there's criminals
and there's people who are not criminals
criminals should die and that's the end
of that she's very Punisher like in
terms of how she functions and in terms
of what she does whereas Captain
America's a lot more lenient everyone
deserves a second chance and that kind
of opinion so the reason why this this
sort of moral quandary plays out is
because they basically end up you know
as they're walking along they end up
running into a guy who's effectively one
of these you know bigshot Wall Street
bankers you know who's just kind of
pissed off because you're not getting
bad loans and not making enough money
and so on and so forth but the Shaolin
scientist Squad intervenes for the
intention of whisking this guy away and
that's what ranch hands been doing he's
been sending his scientists flawed out
into the world and then capturing those
individuals who prey on others now it's
not just bankers it's you know like the
wealthy elite different things like that
and that's the war that he's been waging
and that's really kind of a moral
quandary that's being asked here you
know like with Wall Street bankers and
different things like that you know who
is really at fault here the person who
issued a loan or the person who signed
their name on the dotted line of the
loan they knew they couldn't afford
that's why it creates kind of a funny
scenario and there's only really so much
you can do if like after the the
mortgage crisis of 2008 and army or
vigilantes had walked into Wall Street
and started carrying off all these Wall
Street bankers people probably wouldn't
have batted an eye they probably would
have said yeah man they deserve it but
then if they said okay phase 2 is now to
also take away those people who sign
their names on the dotted lines of homes
they couldn't afford
well then suddenly people would start
freaking out and there'll be excuses the
world well I didn't know I kind of get
stuff but so because of that it creates
kind of this interesting scenario the
fact remains here that this is
tried-and-true Steve Rogers at the end
of the day despite the fact that this
guy is effectively a corporate criminal
despite the fact that this guy is doing
some pretty heinous things he hadn't
broken any literal laws yet he hasn't
actually worked in a particular law
instead he's just a really shady Wall
Street guy and so Captain America is
beholden to the law and the law only and
that's the way its character always
functioned as a sense that he always
went against individuals who violated
the law Captain America was beholden to
the law itself he wasn't beholden to a
government he wasn't beholden to the
average person he was beholden to the
law end of freedom if laws began to
encroach on freedom then he would in
turn battle against those laws in battle
on the side of freedom and so because of
those things he was very much a
patriotic character he was very much a
guy that there was a reflection of
average and normal society the funny
thing about this is that we end up
having the Shaolin scientist squad
basically just kind of like whisk away
you know more or less teleport when the
battle is over and Steve Rogers is
really just kind of left to allow this
guy to be taken by the cops you know to
be taken for treatment and so on and so
forth so again Steve Rogers himself is
really facing this moral quandary
because he looks around and says look
man you're shady banker guy like the
world would legitimately be better off
without you if you just vanished you
know these guys are taking you away and
you were working in some caves the world
not mourn you the world would not miss
you there's nothing in your life of any
significance and so we'd be fine without
you you know but at the end of the day
he is beholden to the law
he's beholden to freedom he's been
holding to the idea that people who
commit crimes or give that things should
be held accountable for that within the
confines of the law and that's really
kind of a nature that that's that's the
knife's edge the Captain America walks
because all as all would ever really
take and this is his argument he's made
time and time again this is an argument
that's been made in Marvel Comics time
and time again especially during the
first civil war all it takes is making
it acceptable one time all it takes is
for someone to come along and say yeah
that person did something bad but the
problem is if there was a trial it would
probably get away with it let's just mix
the trial and just take him out in the
public square and shoot them let's just
do that because then we don't have to
worry about it ensure it would be more
efficient executing people for their
crimes statistically speaking does not
prevent people from committing crimes
it's not a deterrent but it does prevent
repeat offenders the person can't commit
a crime again if they're dead and so
because of that it'd be so much easier
and it would certainly smooth the
process out if people were just executed
on the spot for the cons that they
commit but if you do that once then you
can do it twice and if you can do it
twice you can do it three times and then
four times and five times and suddenly
it becomes a societal standard structure
organization society itself breaks down
on a fundamental level and it's nothing
but the Wild West just a bunch of crazy
people running around with guns shooting
each other up because one guy has
something another guy wants and so
because of that in order to maintain
structure in order to maintain order
rules have to be imposed right wrong or
otherwise they are there and Captain
America fights on behalf of those so
long as they do not encroach on people's
freedom and so again it makes it a
really cool scenario when it comes to
his character how he functions and how
he exists and so what we end up finding
out here is that in the aftermath of the
destruction of this Helicarrier we
essentially have you know Steve Rogers
basically showing up at the behest of
Maria Hill and she of course informs him
the weapons - is basically free and that
weapon - again
basically dr. by the bubble was created
to be a deterrent for Steve Rogers for
Wolverine for all those different guys
it was shields answer to weapon Plus and
so because of that jet also uses her
Omni senses probability to push any one
of her senses to the to the infinite
peak and simply you know use her sight
to realize that you know Sam Wilson
still alive which of course they end up
rescuing him but again the role of dr.
mine bubble begins to come into play
when we have
Nick Fury jr. who has been taken by mine
bubble and while he believes while he
sees inside this illusion that he's
basically tracking down Hydra that
hydras trying to access something called
a gun gear ultimately this is really
just mine bubble using Nick Fury to
activate the machinery itself now we'll
actually find out what that is and it's
really really cool but this is when we
basically get this whole exposition on
what it is that dr. mind the bubble is
about of course we have Captain America
and we have Falcon trying to track down
Nick Fury as well as Mind bubble and so
on but we end up finding out from at
least from what they're told by Maria
hill that initially when weapons class
was first launched with weapon zero with
Captain America Steve Rogers and project
rebirth and when the weapons Plus
project was turned into weapon one and
weapon two 11:3 going all the way up to
weapons 10 or weapons X with wool rain
and then eventually going into Deadpool
and then so on and so forth that shield
realized that if super soldiers were
being cranked out and this kind of
variation and in these extremes shield
would need a countermeasure the problem
with this was that this guy horse little
Tim the one who was leading the project
could not find any legit volunteers
after he had basically taken LSD and
merged it with the Super Soldier Serum
now the answer is not given to us in
terms of how he was able to locate the
Super Soldier Serum because keep in mind
that's the whole core of Captain America
dr. Abraham Erskine formed the Super
Soldier Serum the Super Soldier Serum
was originally intended to be a
deterrent against the expansion of
mutants in the Marvel Universe the
result is that you know following the
creation of Captain America Abraham
Erskine was killed by the Germans and
the secret of the Super Soldier Serum
was lost with him weapons we know two
three four five six going all the way up
to Wolverine and Deadpool those were all
basically attempts to either duplicate
the Super Soldier Serum or create
something wholly different so because
that we don't know how you know it is
that horse Lyttleton God the Super
Soldier Serum if it's even the legit
serum itself it could just be a spin-off
because there were no volunteers he
basically used it on himself and what it
did is it gave him the ability to create
these mind-altering bubbles that are
composed of literal LSD and super
soldier serum and then impose those
bubbles on other people forces in the
sea whatever it is that's inside there
now again horizontal does not control
what people see inside that bubble the
bubbles are basically just emitted from
his mind and sort of thrown out there
and that's really about it I mean the
structure is created by him the
environment is created by him but in
terms of how people experience things in
terms of those individuals who talk
to them force does not have control of
that you know in the case of an expiry
for example it's just here as a dream
where Nick Fury is helping to track down
Hydra and helping to defeat Hydra and
then whatever goes on inside that dream
is basically up to Nick Fury himself in
terms of how his mind construes it but
the fact remains here that with Horace
Milton behind the wheel and with iron
nail continuing to control everything
behind the scenes this ultimately leads
to a direct conflict between these two
shield helicarrier's they literally just
crash into one another now of course
Captain America is doing what he can to
face off against these various guys to
try to bring this Helicarrier down in
this entirety but the fact remains that
with these two shield Helicarrier is
being forced to crash with all of this
happening under the control of Mind
bubble himself it inevitably leads to a
conflict directly between Captain
America and iron nail now this is
effectively when Captain America begins
to lose the Super Soldier Serum and the
reason why is because of the fact that
remember RAM Shan basically has the
ability to emit these tendrils that will
absorb energies atoms out of people
it'll basically absorb what it is that
makes them who they are their life force
or something along those lines but even
then it's not explicitly explained it's
really more like a plot device than
anything else we don't know for example
if iron nail would be able to attack
Kitty Pryde and then like absorb her X
gene we don't know if you will be able
to do things like that he probably
wouldn't the only indication we have of
where you can do is really basically
absorb the Infinity formula the formula
made Nick Fury and dum-dum Dugan young
when he absorbed that serum out of them
and the Nick Fury and dum-dum Dugan grew
really old really fast that's the only
indication of what it is that he can do
and even Captain America makes that
comment he doesn't know what our nail
can do all he knows is that iron nail is
dangerous and so mind if it needs to be
dealt with now this is kind of reprimand
ur playing on the nature of Captain
America right I mean Captain America
isn't the sharpest tool in the shed I
mean he's smart but he's really more of
like let's form a plan somebody else
give me the intelligence that I need and
then when I have that intelligence then
we'll form a plan on what it is that we
should do I mean it's very indicative of
what you would expect from a leader a
leader doesn't have to know everything a
leader just needs to be able to surround
himself with effective people who know
their information so that way he can
play the role of consolidating all that
information
bringing it together and making it a
cohesive clan that's why Captain America
was always a leader of the Avengers but
that's why people like Iron Man are so
essential because they always had an
intrinsic role to play you have Tony
Stark yet Hank Pym
some of the smartest people he always
had a Rain guy that's part of the
Avengers so that you would have that
intelligence aspect and Captain America
could use that in order to form his own
plans and so again in the midst of this
conflict it's exactly as they would
expect mind bubble arrives and traps
Captain America inside one of these
bubbles and this is when we basically
learn the hearts desire of Steve Rogers
what it is that he wants above all else
he is surrounded by friends he does have
jet black he doesn't have Nick Fury
you know Bucky Barnes is there it's
really this idea hey man you made it out
alive and you saved all of us you know
it's so great that you pull this off the
world is celebrating what it is you've
done there's parades all that kind of
good stuff but it's also the arrival or
I guess the fact that ian is still alive
his son was you know basically dead as
well as Sharon Carter who's still alive
who's effectively been discovered and so
because of that this is really kind of
like the perfect life of Steve Rogers
the parade is a reflection of what we
would have expected to see because had
Captain America not been frozen during
World War two when the conflict was over
this is what he would have seen at home
he would have seen parades streamers
celebration all that kind of stuff he
would have seen all of that at the same
time with regards to Sharon Carter and
Ian is basically him having a family
he's a husband and he's a father
and so because that his life is
basically complete he saved the
superhero community and he's got a
family of his own this is really what it
is that he wants the most but in the end
he can't bring himself to accept it
because in his mind it's too perfect now
this is kind of interesting because with
Captain America we always kind of looked
at here we always kind of looked at
Steve Rogers and said okay this is a guy
who is a reflection of an archaic time
this is a guy who is a reflection of an
age when things were a little more pure
naive perhaps but it's not a reflection
of the modern day it's just not how
things are people don't don't talk to
each other the way they used to they
don't you know engage the kind of things
the way they used to and there's all
kinds of arguments you're gonna strap
with extrapolate for that but the fact
remains here that with Steve Rogers
himself looking out on this and saying
there's no possible way that I could be
living in a world that's perfect the
world doesn't exist this way anymore
there's they don't do parades when wars
are won you know they don't do things
like that if this is the world then this
is not the real world this is not my
world to have my wife where haven't have
my future wife back to have my son back
to a saved all the superheroes it
doesn't work that way
the missions over we get debriefed and
then we get briefed on the next mission
that's just how it functions that's just
how it go
there's a million reasons for why this
world can't be real and so of course
Steve Rogers does the only one thing you
can do when it comes to escaping a mind
bubble he basically commits suicide and
that indeed is the only way to get out
of a mind bubble when you're trapped in
one you basically have to kill yourself
but this is why it's so dangerous is
because if the world around you shifts
and you believe it's legitimately real
and you don't have the ability to
distinguish between what's real and
what's false then it's like putting a
gun in the hand of it schizophrenic is
the world that they're living in with a
gun real or is the world without the gun
real which one is true and which one is
false and so that's the crazy situation
it's because if you weren't able to tell
the difference you could be standing in
the real world out of the effects of a
mind though and people are telling you
no no no no do not pull that trigger
you're you're in the real world but to
you you're not in the real world you're
in the mind bubble the gun goes to the
side of your head that your gets pulled
and you are dead that's it there's no
coming back
and so they cuz that's what makes doctor
mind bubbles so dangerous it's because
this shift between real and false could
take place and you would just never know
the fact remains here that was Steve
Rogers escaping this leads directly into
a conflict between himself and iron nail
yet again you know this battle between
the two of them now of course you know
mine bubble is more or less you know
incapacitated when Steve Rogers throws
his shield at mine bubbles head blocked
the access port where the bubbles come
out from and the result is that his mind
just starts filling up with all of his
own dreams and he really kind of goes
crazy and that's the end of that but we
also end up finding out that this gun
gear this device so they've basically
access is a Gundam is a giant gundam no
it's actually just a giant machine
really just kind of like a giant robot
which i guess it is a Gundam but it's a
weapon that shield had created it's a
weapon shield it created for the purpose
of deterring and battling against a
massive threat now it's not being used
for the purpose of like you know
incapacitating the Hulk because truth be
told depending on how strong this
machinery is this find how big it is the
Hulk could probably still tear it apart
so it doesn't really matter on that kind
of scale the idea is that it's really
just another weapon created by a shield
and so the result is that we're you know
this is basically being accessed by iron
nail and it's going to be used for the
intention of just kind of obliterating
you know society as a whole and then
sort of restructuring everything under
iron nail himself the battle between
Captain America and mansion ultimately
leads to Steve Rogers you know having to
go to the central access court throwing
a shield basically destroying the core
thereby destroying the robot and in the
process while he is able to get his shoe
off he's impaled by these tendrils which
begins draining out the Super Soldier
Serum from his body and the result is
that once it's all said and done Ranch
Inn is effectively defeated and then we
basically have old man Steve Rogers he's
now lost a Super Soldier Serum and
that's effectively the end of him and so
what this does is it sets the stage for
a story called The Tomorrow Soldier
which will begin the process of bringing
in Sam Wilson as the new Captain America
in all-new all-different Captain America
so again if you guys are new here to
come and explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
port if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah all this
stuff we have like two more videos and
then we basically not picking up with
secret out with Secret Wars really
all-new all-different marvel so
hopefully where the darts are the way
these videos in because we have the
tomorrow soldiers then we have all new
Captain America and then we're done and
so hopefully the way that all new
Captain America ends for you guys you'll
literally be able to finish that one and
then just go directly into all-new
all-different marvel with Captain
America Sam Wilson number one and just
find this perfect segue between these
two things so that's why we're putting
all this before the secret Empire before
the all-new all-different marvel video
stuff so you guys can just kind of watch
it all in chronological order but anyway
guys are going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end and I'll catch you
all later peace
[Music]
you